In addition to having multiple tapes,
there are other curious variance
of the basic turning machine.
We can restrict them so
that a symbol on any given
square can only be changed once.
We can let them have
two way infinite tapes.
Or even let them be non-deterministic.
We'll examine this idea
when we get to complexity.
All these things are equivalent to
turning machines in the sense that we've
been talking about, and it's good
to know that they're equivalent.
Ultimately, however,
I doubt that the equivalent of those
models does much to convince anyone that
Turing machines capture
the common notion of computation.
To make that argument, we'll show that
a Turing machine is equivalent to
the random access model,
which very closely resembles the basic
CPU register memory paradigm behind
the design of modern computers.
Here is a representation
of the RAM Model.
Instead of operating with a finite
alphabet like a Turing machine,
the RAM model operates with
non-negative integers,
which can be arbitrarily large.
It has registers, useful for storing
operands for basic operations, and
an infinite storage device analogous to
the tape of a regular Turing machine.
I'll call this memory,
for obvious reasons.
There are two key differences
between this memory and
the tape of a regular Turing machine.
One is that each position on
this device stores a number.
And the other is that any element can
be read with a single instruction
instead of having to move ahead
over the tape to the right spot.
In addition to this storage, the machine
also contains the program itself,
expressed as a sequence of instructions.
And a special register
called the program counter,
which keeps track of which
instruction should be executed next.
Every instruction is one of a finite set
that closely resembles
the instructions of assembly code.
For instance,
we have the read instruction,
read j, which reads the contents
from the jth address on the memory.
And places it in register zero.
Register zero, by the way,
has a special status.
And is involved in
almost every operation.
We also have a write operation,
which writes to the jth
address in memory from R0.
If we're moving data between registers,
we have load, which writes to R0.
And store, which writes from it,
as well as add which increases
R0 by the amount in Rj.
All of these operations cause the
program counter to be incremented by one
after they're finished.
To jump around in the list however,
we have a series of
special jump instructions
that changed the program counter,
sometimes depending on the value in R0.
And finally, of course, we have the halt
instruction to end the program.
The final value in R0 determines
whether we accept or reject.
Note that in our definition
here there's no multiplication,
we can achieve that
through repeated addition.
We won't have much use for
the notation surrounding the RAM model.
But nevertheless it's good to write
things down mathematically as
this sometimes sharpens
our understanding.
In this spirit, we say that a random
access Turing machine consists of
a natural number K indicating
the number of registers, and
a sequence of instructions pi.
The configuration of a random access
machine is defined by the counter value
which is 0 for the state.
And indicates the next instruction
to be executed otherwise.
Also, we have the register values and
the values in memory,
which can be expressed as a function.
Note that only a finite number of the
addresses will contain a nonzero value,
so this function always has
a finite representation.
We'll use one-based indexing.
Hence the domain for the tape is
the natural numbers starting from 1.